beijo na boca é coisa do passado agora a
moda é beijar na boca bola rolou o jahia
regional tudo bem vocês eu tô bem cara
se eu vou dizer que estou feliz feliz
faltou água minha filha do meu deus esse
verão está me matando e se vê quando eu
morrer moyens morrer a gente nasce esta
triste onde que morreu de venda não é
tomar aido muito mais e não venda de
hoje resolvi fazer eu já respondi às
perguntas uma vez do facebook com a
verdade foi do twitter e agora vou
responder às perguntas do instagram
atirar forte tinha o que o filho porque
uma família está grampo pra fazer
perguntas eu pedi a galera jaburu mil
facebook
a pergunta é a desgraça que é isso
então quem segue está grande perguntou
eu vou responder que não me sem então da
próxima vez vou perguntar no instagram é
bom você me sinta o tamanho está a
gastar essa que o windows phones tudo
juntos e pesquisa esse nome que está
aqui no seu instagram a seguir ao que
seguirão pronto e vai receber a iprint
dos vídeos fotos muito legais
interessante que eu posso um dia a dia
porque eu sou o que sou muito bem mas é
isso aí vamos à pergunta você faz o
personagem nos seus vídeos ou é você
mesmo e se faz agora desrespeito por
ignorância abraço é o jackson e joe
jackson ao não o que está aqui nos meus
vídeos sou eu o que acontece quando eu
estou na frente dessa câmera eu me
satírico eu sou realmente uma pessoa
assim eu sou a pessoa que alega opção
traz piadas uma pessoa assim porém aqui
nos vídeos eu fico muito muito muito
mais engraçado mas talvez a pessoa viver
na rua e vi que eu to com pouco capital
mas eu sou assim a rebeca
liberta mês repete o mesquita aí pega o
mesquita além do qual foi a coisa mais
esquisita que já aconteceu contigo um
beijo na minha área é minha amiga laís
um beijo para mais 15 que o seu desejo é
que eu sonhei que estava ocorrendo
naquele gramado não está ligado aquele
gramado da tela do windows seu sonho
está correndo no gramado isso e eu muito
papo com deus e ao pt na tela do
computador
eu acordei assassinato do animal com
denis zé luís sabe outra coisa que eu
sou e muito estranha só isso hoje a
vocês é nosso único como quando eu
sonhei que tinha bebido muito e aí eu
comecei a vomitar luçon entendeu
vomitasse sabe quando você vomita fica a
gente usa rossa guitarras e passion e
cospe eu sou eu estava vomitando sonham
time para evitar nunca vai vomitar
oficial a meu muito cara quando eu fui
com os que eu acordei eu o curso de
pintura também me achando muito muito
muito doido a oi anita pergunta quais
cidades você tem vontade de conhecer
eu tenho muita vontade de conhecer natal
aracaju e curitiba e eu vou ver o que a
santa sé não sabe que eu sou eu sou eu o
[Música]
andré alencar que dito vem a holanda eu
falo que eu só quem faz as pessoas a
pensar tentação fora do normal não só a
situação fora do normal de sustentação
ostentação sabe assim a sentar sozinha a
citação assim esse pequeno a roda x
adelaide apertando sente falta da casa
dos pais da moda pela irlanda em londres
sabe que é assim de fato meu pai
ela está em casa é tudo tão assim mas é
tudo por conta dos outros a gente sempre
está sendo servida também está na
própria casa da gente é tão difícil tem
pai pra gente parar assim pensar onde
está meu tese e aí você chama a mãe da
gente com calma se mãe deles não têm
muita saudade
o ief é então você tem nossa o im anos
faleceu um dia ruim se eu fico mesmo é
carinhoso nápoles carinho você tem noção
de quantos anos você tem de quantas
pessoas você faz feliz por todo brasil
beijo e ela manda beijo pra mim um beijo
da lei linha à qual eu estou eu com 40
anos e têm por mim mas é que eu faço um
trabalho que eu pensar deus que eu nunca
a minha ideia porque eu to gosta tanto
de fazer quando eu não tinha que falar
assim dói cantonês do eu falar assim do
delegado é muito bom do gosto meio
óptico feliz é obrigada a todos vocês
brigar bem por força da com todo o do
ipi perguntou wilson e nordeste chove
chove porque a tempestade de areia não é
certo que às vezes algumas pessoas têm
preconceito mas algumas pessoas tão
brincando pelas falhas piada eu senti
que estava brincando aqui eu quem também
não mas o que chama mesmo inclusive tava
chovendo muito esses dias vocês já
puderam ver os vídeos meus passado que
casa alagou uma vez button não são e um
banheiro na sala enquanto tinha e também
cante atacar isso adiantou qual seu
maior sonho em ser humano bem pra mim
cada tinha muito sonho de conhecer o stb
conhecia o cara [ __ ]
bom a gente [ __ ] gente boa de maio deu
maior atenção ea partir daí eu comecei a
me inspirar muito trabalho dele minha
sincera desculpa velho poderoso e eu
comecei a estudar e se eu ainda sou
muito existe tutano olha sr explica que
a idéia é começar a estudar aqui tão
grotowski chá chá preto duprat um dia eu
conseguir lotar teresina raul local
sciarra 14 mil pessoas para assistir
falando né esse no momento está sendo
meu sonho agora eu quero que quando
falasse gente vou fazer um show e natal
gente vou fazer um show em aracaju eu
vou fazer um show em manaus gente eu vou
fazer um show em teresina fortaleza e se
eu quero todo mundo lá fazem de tudo
para me assistir porque você é tudo que
eu quero na minha vida a galera tem a
galera tem 2093 perguntas aqui é
impossível muito obrigado a todo mundo e
mandou perguntas 8 não acredita e 32
simplicado gostei não
é esse malbec estou ainda minha fã todi
negro do tempo não porque gostei pra
ajudar nós estamos rumo a um milhão de
inscritos estão perto a gente estamos
perto então daquele gostei de escreve o
canal
muito obrigado a todo mundo pego se você
ainda não me segue estagnada é só seguir
aqui o s instagram aqui na próxima vez
eu perguntava você já vai estar lá você
vai perguntar eu vou responder na banda
treinos é muito feliz
muito obrigada por testes e tive até
aqui até amanhã